and now on afterwards Matt Lewis the
author of too dumb to fail he looks at
the origins of the conservative movement
and argues that the Republican Party
needs to return to its roots in order to
avoid becoming a minority party he's
interviewed by SE Cupp columnist for the
New York Daily News
so Matt first when did you start writing
this book because it brilliantly
predicts sort of the the landscape of
where we are now with this election it's
so timely take me through the the
process of when this all formed in your
head well I think I did get lucky with
the timing somebody said I should buy a
Powerball ticket because I can just see
the future you know it's hard to say
when winner when do you start writing a
book you know is it when you write the
proposal was it when you turn in the
manuscript I would actually say about
five years ago I started writing columns
which ultimately led me to this book and
it was around the time that Sarah Palin
went rogue you know I had initially
thought syrupy I had like Sarah Palin I
thought after the race she kind of got
radicalized and sort of changed and I
started seeing candidates like Christine
O'Donnell and Sharron Angle who were
saying some things that I felt kind of
uncomfortable with as a conservative
they were playing identity politics they
were kind of casting themselves as a
victim playing the victim card which
struck me as unconservative and you know
it was it sort of a populist tone that
got me writing about this topic and
ultimately led to the week my book comes
out Sarah Palin endorses Donald Trump
and I mean how how could I plan that you
know you couldn't really amazing timing
and well let's get back to the election
because there's lots to discuss there
that aligns with your message but first
remind people of the intellectual
history
of conservatism I you know I know when I
go to when I go to colleges I tell
students you'd be surprised to learn
that you know the rock stars that the
Manhattan cocktail parties used to be
conservatives the Irving Kristol and
Iran talk about that rich that rich
history well in fact there was a time
not that long ago when the knock against
conservatives was that they were too
intellectual that they were to academic
and and and pointy-headed intellectuals
who couldn't actually appeal to the
common Joe Sixpack man it's completely
the opposite today of course but you
know a lot of people think that the
intellectual father of conservatism is
actually Aristotle which puts
conservatism and very good you know
intellectual company but certainly the
modern leader a modern you know
conservative is Edmund
Birk the British parliamentarian who you
know famously was you know very
supportive of the American cause but
famously against the French Revolution
you know this is a guy who you know has
been incredibly influential and if you
look at the the the sort of battle that
he had the intellectual battle that
Edmund Burke had against Thomas Paine
you have the birth of the the the right
in the left even to this day and Burke
you know believed in that in preserving
tradition and that Western civilization
didn't just miraculously happen that it
was the product of accumulated wisdom
and so you know modern conservatives
harken back to Burke I would say that
the modern American conservative most
modern yeah yeah really starts in a
right you know as a reaction to FDR and
the New Deal yeah and you have again
brilliant men mostly men like Hayek and
you know eventually what Iran would be a
woman as sort of a libertarian woman who
certainly contributed to that people
like Russell Kerr Richard Weaver that
leads us to the Paul y roots of the
world the William F Buckley 's and so
there's a really rich intellectual
tradition that I think in recent years
we've gotten away from as we've kind of
dumbed down conservatism to win votes
well I think and tell me if you agree
there's they're still contemporary
intellectuals within the movement people
like Mark Steyn I would I would offer
Thomas Sol but they seem to be getting
marginalized they're not getting as much
attention as some other folks why do you
think that is well any part of its the
product of our culture you know you have
the entertainment wing of the Republican
Party really kind of dominating and so
you know you've all Levin can write
something really fabulous
but if Rush Limbaugh says something mean
about Sandra Fluke or if Ann Coulter
says something on cable news what is
going to get the most attention right
and so really you know my
book to dump to fail the title harkens
to the too-big-to-fail ya mentality
where in the case of too big to fail you
obviously had financial institutions who
had perverse incentives to take risks
that ultimately we the taxpayers would
bail them out and I think you have a
similar dynamic in the conservative
movement right now with politicians and
pundits where if you're a political
pundit it's kind of in your best
interest you have a perverse incentive
to say something controversial or
provocative even if the conservative
movement cumulatively is harmed by it
yes I can I can I hear you there and I
want to get back to talk radio because I
think bringing up Rush Limbaugh's an
important point but first I just want to
read from too dumb to fail for a minute
and have you comment you write too many
of today's conservatives deliberately
shun erudition academic excellence
experienced sagacious nests and
expertise in politics many of the people
doing so are not as dumb as they pretend
to be even those rare conservatives who
possess a wealth of knowledge feel
obliged to act dumb and I think that's
what you're talking about this desire to
put on an effect of yeah of dumbness
when when did that become a thing I
think you know the books call it to dump
to fail and then there's a thing that I
believe it's called too smart to win
where you basically have to feign
ignorance or at least a sort of everyman
populism in order to get ahead and to
pander to voters and it's really
unfortunate you know a lot of the people
who do this are highly intelligent I
mean Donald Trump is this you know
billionaire who went to an Ivy League
school who's obviously playing this game
Ted Cruz no I read a polemic resume and
cachet and again pandering to the sort
of the populist conservative thing but
the really sad part is the candidates
who try to do it and can't Bobby Jindal
Rhodes Scholar incredibly intelligent
conservative tried desperately to to
pander and to be in every man and just
didn't work and I think really sadly
Scott Walker who doesn't
the academic resume but a very smart and
capable governor who you know really
could have been the bridge between the
establishment and the grassroots but
instead you know decided he had to win
Iowa he had to pander to Iowa voters and
he started embracing things like
birthright citizenship which kind of
went against his brand earlier and so
basically we have this scenario where
you know basically you have to pretend
to be something you're not and the the
unfortunate part is that that in order
to pander to say like Republican primary
voters in Iowa you have to adopt a purse
tot of persona and a style that would
actually hurt you when it comes to
winning over Millennials or cosmopolitan
Americans who I believe actually should
be voting conservative but are turned
off by the the cultural baggage and the
stylistic stereotypes of what we think
of when we think of conservatives and
you're not suggesting that populism writ
large is all bad right I mean there's
some there's some good you know I think
Ronald Reagan was was able to
successfully marry an intellectual
conservatism with a you know vigorous
populism yeah absolutely that's one of
the things that I try to define in the
book is like what there are a lot of
words that we bandy about I I'm guilty
of it too just because you need
shortcuts but what do they mean and one
of the many words is populism
I mean if populism means somebody who
believes in the American people instead
of the establishment or the elites then
I actually might qualify as a populist
but unfortunately populism oftentimes
leads to a sort of a pandering and a
demagoguery and you know if you look at
some of the modern populist say for
example George Wallace you know we see
that there's a sort of a pernicious
strain that comes along with populism
where they basically have to find
somebody to blame for their woe you know
it's a philosophy
that if you're not careful can devolve
into a sort of a woe is me we can't get
ahead those other people are stopping us
from being successful and to me that's
patently unconservative that's not a
rugged individualism that believes if
you work hard you can get ahead
achieve the American dream that's that
that is something that I think is is not
conservative and is actually harmful to
the human spirit you know at a sort of a
micro level do you think in some ways
that all of this into into dumb to fail
is a reaction to the liberal secular
elite project I'm thinking in the in the
mostly in the 2000s sort of the what's
the matter with Kansas um you know
projects that liberals kind of looked at
the flyover States and said you guys are
a bunch of rubes you're not voting your
interests you're just clinging to you
know guns and religion and so
conservatism so okay we'll take care of
you guys we will be your voice I I would
imagine you would agree that that's
that's a good impulse but that it just
happened wrong well what I would say is
I think that if you if conservatives are
saying shut up at this I think that
there's a mistake when you let the other
side define who you are and I think
that's so often conservatism in in
recent years has been defined as
whatever Obama's for were again right so
on the rare occasion that Obama's for
something good like let's say free-trade
we must reflexively be against it and
the problem with that is when you allow
the other guy if you if you have a
knee-jerk reaction to be against
whatever the other person's for you're
actually letting him define the
parameters of the debate so I think
that's been an unfortunate result now I
think this this weird phenomenon is is
really there are there many factors that
are leading us where we are I think some
of it is Barack Obama's presidency which
I don't think has been helpful for the
country and I think has led to a lot of
Americans to feel disillusioned and I
also think they're just trends like
globalization industrial you know Kay
you could if you're Bernie Sanders and
you're an outsider you can blame
capitalism if you're Donald Trump you
might blame immigration but there's
automation globalization all sorts of
things are feeding into this and I and I
do fully appreciate that there are a lot
of Americans who are angry upset and
frustrated
and I don't I mean I think at least some
of that desire is understandable and I
can certainly identify with it yeah well
I talked about the role of evangelicals
because that's been a huge part of
modern conservatism and modern
Republican coalition and you argue that
attempting to win and keep those voters
has been a little bit damaging a little
bit so the book basically the premise of
the book is that conservatism started
out as in thoughtful intellectual
philosophy that it got dumbed down and
then the last part is how we can
actually get it back and restore
conservatism and in a way look backward
to restore the good things about it as
an intellectual force but also look
forward and make it appeal to 21st
century Americans but along the way and
telling that story I document how the
dumbing down happened and part of the
way it happened was we have what I refer
to as immigrants into the conservative
movement this is could be a confusing
word but you know we're always hearing
about the problem of immigrants coming
to America and how they need to be
assimilated and if they're not
assimilated immigrants can change the
country and eventually you wake up and
it's a country you don't recognize and I
argue that political movements and
parties are the same way you always want
new and influx of new people to be
joining your cause or your party but
they need to be assimilated and if
they're not eventually you wake up and
you don't recognize the party that you
are and so conservatism over the years
has had different waves of immigrants
who have come into the Republican Party
and one of them in the late 1970's and
early 1980s were evangelicals who helped
Ronald Reagan win the election but I
also argue they brought in with them
some less than positive attributes
I actually am an evangelical and I read
about in the book that I really believe
it's important that people of faith be
involved in politics one of my heroes is
William Wilberforce who had a religious
he was a member of parliament had a
religious conversion helped lead the
fight against the British slave trade
and I think that's an example of how
people who are people of faith can be
involved in politics and really make a
positive difference unfortunately in
America if you look at the modern
history of even
Jellicle ISM since about 1925 and the
post World War one area era you had the
Scopes Monkey Trial
and it's really hard to underestimate
the profound impact that had on people
on evangelicals specifically in America
and unfortunately we had a situation
where basically you had to make a choice
you were either going to be an
intellectual or you were going to be an
evangelical and the two were really it
was a false choice but they were really
seen as mutually exclusive and so you
can sort of extrapolate that forward for
about 50 years and you basically have a
situation where a lot of the people who
were joining the conservative movement
to help Ronald Reagan were actually anti
intellectual they were very skeptical of
anything that might be perceived as
intellectual and I think that while
there were some good things to come from
that we're today sort of paying the
price with a stereotype of Republicans
being the stupid party so how do you you
know obviously conservatives in the
Republican Party still wants to be the
home for people of rigorous faith how do
you suggest the party reach out to
evangelicals like you whilst not
sounding anti science well the good news
is that in recent years I think
evangelicals have made great strides at
sort of marrying you know sort of
they're brought full thoughtful
understanding and appreciation of
science and popular culture with a
devout faith so there's no longer this
you know decision like you can either
believe in the virgin birth or you can
be taken serious all right and I think
that candidates like Marco Rubio and
he's tapped a guy named Eric Tetzel yeah
who's a young up-and-coming evangelical
this is this is a much more in keeping
with I would say the modern young
evangelical movement is very different
from what we saw with the sort of the
the the I don't know culture wars silent
majority era our parents in great Wow
exactly so they're less it's less
righteous indignation less culture
warrior stuff but still
of devout faith and they actually have
these interesting nuanced positions
where they simultaneously can believe
that God used evolution and that the
earth could be billions of years old and
the Nicene Creed and that God created
the universe and put it all in motion
and they believe in the virgin birth and
they believe in the resurrection
so we're eliminating that false choice
which I think plagued us for so long
well and let's talk about young people
because Millennials are the largest
generation in history there's 80 million
of them they've been taken for granted
by liberals and virtually ignored by
conservatives as a voting bloc
Millennials today have a deep distrust
of government isn't now the perfect
opportunity for conservatives to reach
out to young people maybe have them for
life and how do we do that I couldn't
agree more and as much as much as my
book lays out a lot of problems
conservatives face and conundrums
demographically there's a huge
opportunity right now because in a way
if you think of it Hillary Clinton's
version of liberalism is really a 20th
century command and control you know
factory model of government I mean it
really is it's a it's a top-down
antiquated version of government
assembly line government and if you
compare it to I always tell I always
talk about this if you're a young lady
living in a city and you get order an
uber on your smartphone and then you get
in the car and you get on StubHub and
you order a concert tickets right you I
think are conservative because number
one you're not gonna believe in onerous
government regulations that would stifle
creativity and apps like uber your
entrepreneurial I think by definition at
this point by virtue of what you're
doing you're probably not gonna want the
government to manage your retirement
funds when you're probably managing your
stock your stock market portfolio on
your smartphone you ought to be at that
point of conservative and you probably
in a sense are you just don't know it
but if your view of what conservatism
means is that you have to look like Boss
Hogg and ride around with a confederate
flag in the back here
Trott you're not gonna be a conservative
right and is why I'm actually optimistic
I think there are candidates people like
Marco Rubio and Paul Ryan who are really
legitimate conservative candidates but
who also have the potential to tap into
and sell conservatism to a 21st century
American audience that would be
different than than the coalition that
we are used to do you think it's
possible that Republicans in the near
future
can win over Millennials there's this a
very long-term project in your view well
I think you always have to go into
anything with the assumption that it's a
long-term project but I really think we
are at a crossroads right now I mean the
party of you know Marco Rubio and Paul
Ryan sends a dramatically different
message maybe for a generation than the
party of Donald Trump and we don't know
what direction we're gonna go as a
movement or a party but it could send a
very different direction now I would say
that you know Donald Trump's philosophy
of sort of doubling down on
working-class white older rural southern
married voters is in the short term not
a crazy idea but it's sort of like
getting a reverse mortgage I think in
the long term it's probably not the best
move if you want to win the future not
to say that we should sell out the
current conservative base but either way
I think right now Trump is basically
arguing well we're going to appeal these
new people these Democrats who haven't
been voting they've been staying home so
either what either direction involves
bringing in some new people into the
coalition it's just a matter of which
people are actually growing in terms of
a demographic population well and I want
to talk more about Trump later but
doesn't he have a point you know the
Democrats have been bleeding older white
blue-collar men there are no Reagan
Democrats there are no Blue Dogs anymore
and isn't Donald Trump right that
someone like him could finally get those
people who have been stay
home not to vote for Hillary Clinton or
Bernie Sanders but to vote for him no I
think it's possible actually and I think
in the short term it could work I'm not
one of these people see I believe that
the real problem with Donald Trump is a
long-term problem it's a branding
problem and it's a long-term
mathematical problem but I'm not one of
these people who is convinced that it's
crazy in the short term I actually think
it's feasible that Donald Trump actually
could change the game and change and and
and pick up voters who feel like they've
been left behind absolutely yeah yeah so
let's shift for a minute this is always
bothered me why do conservatives want to
make every subculture wackjob du jour
yeah
the standard bearer of the movement I'm
thinking of clive in bundy Kim Davis
George Zimmerman I mean it's like we we
see a crazy person so oh they should run
for president yeah it's one thing to
defend certain principles and in each
one of those cases there's something
there to defend right but how do we stop
embracing people who make us look bad
yeah it's not even crazy people I don't
I don't think dr. ben Carson is crazy
but we sort of thrust him into the press
and do a presidential race when he
shouldn't have been doing that it should
have been running for a you know no you
should be a doctor that would be good
here he's a really good doctor and think
of it if you really care about the
conservative cause who's more valuable a
guy who runs for president amongst what
17 people or a guy who is a leading you
know neurosurgeon who's african-american
you know and who is pro-life and talks
about a culture of life like I would
argue he was actually more valuable
before he ran for president in terms of
advancing especially now that this race
is damaged yes oh absolutely but
everybody wants to start at the top and
I think that the Conservatives have some
weird things happening one there's a
penchant for lost causes to their dogs
right and underdogs and two there's well
there's also a sense that the enemy of
the enemy the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
right so like Don Imus was never a
conservative he's like a vulgar or old
cowboy but as soon as the politically
correct
you know liberal
I thought police went after him we like
reflexively defendant right well why
just because he's the victim of these
horrible people doesn't mean he's like
Edmund a little Edmund Burke or
something
I think the another issue that happens
to ironically we talk we're always
talking about Hollyweird and the left
coast and all that but we are like the
most the biggest fanboys for celebrity
yeah and usually it's never a list
celebrities who decide it's sort of like
how people find Jesus in prison like
people discover that they're
conservatives only after their career
has sort of flamed out in Hollywood and
they have nothing to and will just
welcome them with open arms right so
it's just it's so weird and I document
that in the book this trend that I think
is part of the dumbing down look you
turn on a cable news show I don't want
to hear the duck dynasty guys talking
politics I don't think that a NASCAR
driver is necessarily the best person to
talk to me about whether or not eminent
domain is good policy but that's what
we're getting in a lot of political
commentary nowadays but isn't it also I
mean isn't the issue also that look you
know I love Kid Rock I don't mind
yeah no I don't mind you know if Tony
Stewart has a political opinion he's
entitled to it and as much as I am and
he can talk about it as can Ben Affleck
that's fine but isn't the bigger problem
the hypocrisy on our side that we
completely dismiss Hollywood and
celebrities as irrelevant and stupid and
unimportant until one comes out for our
side and then it's Clint Eastwood is
coming to the convention then he's going
to talk to an empty chair that's
fantastic Richard if this was had a Ted
Cruz rally right yeah no I think you're
right it's it's it's a lot of hypocrisy
and we just right off the culture I
think mistakenly we write off Hollywood
and in the entertainment world except
when it suits us well and I had this
long-running debate with Andrew
Breitbart before he passed about whether
and we disagreed whether we wanted to
court the Hollywood you know artistic
celebrity kind of culture and
play in that space and so make
conservative projects make conservative
movies or whether we wanted to just be
really good at being conservative and I
don't I don't think you can do both it
gets very tricky as we're discussing
what's your what's your opinion well I
actually I think I probably agree with
Andrew
I believe that politics is downstream
from culture and I think it's important
that people who have a conservative
worldview becoming more involved in the
arts and but see I think it's different
than trotting them out to talk about
politics right they actually shouldn't
be talking about politics right it
should be people who are conservative of
a conservative worldview who happen to
be really good at making movies or
telling jokes or cooking you know being
a chef whatever it is in the in the
culture I think it's a mistake when we
politicize them then you have what
happened to dr. Carson actually he would
have been much better staying out of the
sort of overt political arena and
weighing in sort of at on the edges
helping create a culture of life for
example okay so I want I want names who
are among the worst the worst people
perpetuating this too dumb to fail in
impulse in modern contemporary
conservatism well I think too for me to
name them as and also also in a sense a
compliment well because the people who
are the worst or people who are notable
I mean there are people who have made an
impact I mean the worst person in the
world nobody knows who they are and
they're there you know sitting at home
not yeah so take this as a badge of
honor people I will say let me just
throw one name out that's a really big
name it's a name you've talked about
before I know which is Rush Limbaugh
mm-hmm I have an interesting
relationship with Rush not that I know
him but my you know my dad who was a
prison guard turned me on to listening
to Russia's show around 1988 when he
went national and I probably wouldn't be
sitting here if it wasn't for Rush I
mean I listened to his show all the time
he really helped inspire me but over the
years I do feel like Rush
has abdicated this responsibility that I
think he would have had in a classic
example was was Donald Trump and you had
a lot of talk radio host Mark Levin
being another name who lately have sort
of turned on Trump yeah but for a long
time they provided him cover yeah and
they helped this monster essentially
grow to a point where they couldn't stop
them and I think that you know you they
can say well I'm just an entertainer or
whatever the cop-out is but I do miss
the days when you had someone like
William F Buckley who accepted the sort
of the mantle of leadership and the
responsibility it's really hard now
there aren't a lot of gatekeepers left
who have the the impre mater and the
juice to essentially police the right
and to say no you've gone too far you're
hurting the cause I think rush is one of
the few people left who actually had
people get mad at me when I say this but
the moral authority on the right to call
out Trump initially and to say no he's
not a conservative and I think rush
missed that opportunity and I don't know
if it was because he goes to Mar Lago
and hangs out with trauma right I don't
know if it's because he just liked the
fact that Trump was taking on the
politically correct right whatever news
or when yeah
or if it was because you know he thought
he was a stalking horse for Ted Cruz and
it was whatever the reason being I was a
little disappointed well and I as you
note I have run into rush I merely
suggested not long ago no it was right
after 20 2012 I believe I merely
suggested that once in a while
conservatives should feel free to
disagree with people like Rush Limbaugh
and you'd think I had spit on the Pope I
mean there's just this you know he's
almost untouchable so it takes a lot of
courage to call out people like Rush or
Ann Coulter right on I name names in the
ball and Coulter is one of the one of
the names I name yeah I mean have you
gotten backlash because I know I I do
when I do that and it's it's hard
because you want you know you've you
felt welcomed in this community for so
long and then all of a sudden you're
sacrilege I have to say I've been
stunned at the
positive reception this book has gotten
and I think it's because we've arrived
at a point where people where
conservatives are fed up with people who
exploit the movement and people who
actually hurt the movement
I've had people like Eric Erickson tweet
positive things about this book you know
he's a talk radio host himself yeah and
a conservative blogger and and now
author
I've had people the Weekly Standard
wrote a great review
Henry Olson wrote a fabulous review in
the end the Weekly Standard about this
book I just spoke with the leadership
Institute's Wednesday wake up breakfast
they're a conservative organization
where I used to work and I'm telling you
so many people I said like Donald Trump
many many people have come up to me but
every single person came up and like I'm
glad you wrote this book I completely
worthy I was expecting pushback and when
I first started writing these columns
five years ago I got a ton of push right
if I dare to say anything bad about
Christine O'Donnell I was a Rhino a
sellout a swish I think that the timing
of this is right in so many ways
including the fact that people are fed
up I mean when Ann Coulter tweets out
something where I'm paraphrasing but she
said I don't care if Donald Trump
performs abortions in the White House
right as long as he has this hardcore
anti-immigration immigration policy that
I think people are finally waking up and
even a lot of conservatives who were
hesitant to to engage in introspection
or or sort of criticism of the
conservative cause or finally like reach
critical mass look under the hood and
yeah so do you think I mean all of these
very successful and arguably talented
phases of the party for the past 10 20
years like rush like an are they on
their way out
or are they are we going to have to kind
of all live together for the next you
know decade or so that's a good question
I wonder if we're not in the midst of a
reordering where you basically have a a
conservative movement that I would be a
part of that that believes you know in
in small government and free trade that
free markets help bring about
flourishing you know and and you know
help humans to basically reach their
potential and the most joy the most
prosperity and a more populist nativist
party / movement that basically is for
protectionism wants to build walls and
essentially becomes a as I think been
Dominic said a a white european-style
white identity politics party right and
that's what I'm really hoping we don't
get to because I I fear that we could be
headed to a direction where our politics
is no longer decided about based on
ideas or philosophy it becomes
essentially where do you what Treiber us
and so if you're if you're a college
graduate or a minority you just
automatically are assigned a democratic
guard and if you are a working-class
white person you just reflexively become
a Republican and I think that politics
should be about ideas and we should have
this vigorous debate about ideas and you
shouldn't identity politics should not
define your identity should not define
your political persuasion yeah I mean
that's that's what liberalism does let's
let them I know and that's the sad part
is in many ways we are aping liberal
right and and then conservative there's
a conservative argument that always says
well they do it too or we have to fight
fire with fire I mean I reject that why
should we try to emulate the worst
characteristics of liberalism well and I
want to be very clear here you say
modern eyes don't moderate you are not
suggesting a watering down of
conservative principles or sort of you
know cleansing the party of its
staunchest social and cultural beliefs
what does modernizing look like for you
right well that's actually a very
important point I'm glad you brought it
up because so many people who have
written books about how to fix the
Republican Party or the conservative
movement their recipe is just oh be come
more liberal yes stop talking about
abortion so much yeah exactly right and
I mean I was at a a book party recently
a sort of a swanky a nice nice affair
and I don't
do a lot of the Georgetown cocktail
parties but this is sort of a
stereotypical thing and somebody said to
me what do you think of John Kasich and
I said he seems like the kind of he
seems like the what liberals think would
be the perfect idea of a Republican
though that mirror I know he's a very
good governor a very popular governor
but in terms of the presidential nominee
for me he was a non-starter and I just
he doesn't appeal to me and I knew he
wouldn't resonate but to a certain type
of liberal know to a person is every
Democrat I talk to you say oh well John
Kasich is your best chance oh yeah and
I'm like you guys are so out of it but
but that's the sense and that is not
what I'm advocating that you know I
actually to me right now I mean I think
Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz are sort of the
two guys who I think sort of best embody
true movement conservatism I think
probably Rubio probably taps more into
the modernized don't moderate thing I
think he could appeal to to the sort of
the 21st century and maybe millennial
voter in a way that the cruise couldn't
but both of these guys are young smart
legitimate conservatives no I'm not
advocating becoming more liberal in fact
I'm saying Donald Trump is advocating
becoming more liberal right he just
seems to be conservative because we
conflate toughness and anger with
conservatism now I would I would venture
to say if you were to go down the list
and have like a litmus test of things I
believe in and compare it to Donald
Trump and Ann Coulter I would be by
definition much more conservative on
almost you know every issue so I'm you
know I'm strongly pro-life I'm for low
taxes strong national defense me
whatever whatever it is but I'll go back
to my story about uber as an example of
what I'm talking about modernizing not
moderating it's not about changing your
position and becoming more pro-abortion
to attract more voters it's about having
a party and a movement that doesn't
viscerally and reflexively turn off
people who are conservative they just
don't know it yet right right well so I
mean is that is that an issue of talking
differently or is it an issue of voting
differently you know how do we get there
how do we modernize right now right so I
have three chapters on this top
hahaha so there's a lot to it but I
think some of it could be a site I hate
to you know subscribe to the great man
theory of politics but having the right
nominee really can make a difference I
mean just symbolically speaking Donald
Donald Trump nominee is very different
than Marco Rubio nominee right and Marco
Rubio president for four or eight years
speaking Spanish fluently talking about
his father being a bartender you know
that that line he has that journey from
behind that bar to behind this podium as
the essence of the American dream that
goes a long way I think also obviously
movements need to have think tanks they
need to actually try to identify a
recruit train in place future leaders to
help change that's what the dlc dead
when they modernize the Democratic Party
so there's a lot of things that happen I
think that opinion leaders and elections
writers certainly can nudge the world a
little bit so to speak in the right
direction but this is a I mean this
isn't pretty look we didn't get into
this mess overnight yeah and it's not
gonna be fixed overnight either yeah
well and so let's let's really get in to
this election because it's not just a
way to talk about the news but I mean
this book really does to them to fail
really does talk directly to the time we
live in and I know you wrote it before a
lot of this happened because that's how
long it takes to write a book and get
thankfully right thankfully I was able
to end every draft got more and more
Trump wasn't even running when I started
right right amazing why but I'd actually
seen these trends that became trumpism
yeah you know sort of bubbling up but I
didn't know that Trump was gonna be the
vessel that they would manifest Mazin
yeah but so do you think that this this
current election is just a trump problem
or if he hadn't run with someone else be
giving us the same kind of agita the
same you know putting the same kind of
face on the party because that's where
we just are at right now no I think that
that this because I started writing the
book before Trump Rand I think that this
would have manifested another way it
might have been somebody like Ted Cruz
might have tapped into it or there
might have been another third-party
candidate who want Davis for example
maybe Ben Carson catches fire and and
doesn't flame out and he was for a while
they are doing pretty well no I think
that this this is not solely a Trump
phenomenon but I think that Donald Trump
was very uniquely able to cap I think he
identified this moment in a way that
nobody else did and was able to
demagogue the issues in a way that very
few people would have been capable of
based on his PR ability so he saw this
coming he saw it as I think a business
opportunity and I think he really
exploited it in a way that I don't know
that other candidates could have fully
gone full populist to the degree that he
did would they have I mean look this
group of people that Donald Trump is
appealing to that always existed right
and at times they found Democrats more
appealing at times they found
Republicans more appealing but this
group of people who's very angry and
afraid and looking for people to blame
always there he's really just the first
candidate running for president who
publicly identified them because for
anyone else it would have been very
perilous you know I've done so I think
you know obviously throughout history
going back to Andrew Jackson we've had
populist candidates and William Jennings
Bryan and George Wallace Pat Buchanan is
sort of similar I like Pat he tapped
into this a little bit yeah but the
country when he was doing it the country
wasn't as angry wasn't as frustrated I
think the timing is better for Trump to
to sell this now there were other
candidates in more recent history who
nibbled around the edges of this I think
Mike Huckabee and Rick Santorum who both
won Iowa and 2008 and 2012 respectively
sort of tapped into the populist thing
but they never really went they never
fully won they never went full truant
probably because they're actually
conservative to a certain degree
decent people and that yeah they would
you have to be completely shameless to
go all in on it
yeah but they nibbled around the edges
but I think Trump has really just fully
exploited this moment in a way that that
almost uniquely nobody else could have
to the degree he dead yeah well and I
think
also learned through Trump that nuance
is no longer a really valuable commodity
you know for someone like Rand Paul for
example who has very nuanced positions
and and I for one was very grateful
every time we got to hear his point of
view even when I disagreed with it
there just didn't seem to be oxygen for
people like Rand Paul with nuanced views
do we get do we get that back or as
nuanced gone for good well I think that
that's an interesting question because I
think in some and some ways this is
cyclical we've always had the rise of
populist candidates and even throughout
history we had oscillating between sort
of intellectual elites and populism and
it's gone back and forth I mean like
think for example you know you have
people like Andrew Jackson who obviously
were you know populist or hick or a
fast-forward a century and you've got
like John F Kennedy the the best and the
brightest so throughout history we've
had different moments but I also think
that's while some of its cyclical and
there's also a linear thing happening
where our politics is gradually getting
just progressively dumbed down and both
sides are just on on the right I think
this is a bipartisan phenomenon yeah I
but however I think that it is
disproportionately hit Republicans for a
couple reasons one is that Democrats
have already had their time in the
wilderness where they had to sort of go
through their identity crisis they've
had a couple of those moments right the
last one sort of ended in 1992 when they
you know sort of gave up the the
limousine liberal Michael Dukakis thing
and and went with the southern governor
at least that not was what they had to
do and the era of Reagan and the 90s in
order to finally win they had to lose
three presidential elections before they
had that kind of come to Jesus moment
where they would go with Clinton and I
think right now Democrats are more
disciplined they have a president they
have the bully pulpit he can sort of
impose order Republicans are now in the
wilderness searching going through this
identity crisis and so they're I think
more susceptible to the the whims
happening out there and trying to find
who they are you know and and and you
know one example - is that how
technology has changed things okay so
for example technology and the culture
not that long ago political party ball
it wasn't that longer that political
party bosses and smoke-filled back rooms
helped decide who was the nominee Donald
Trump would have never had never gotten
started right it wasn't that long ago
when there wasn't 24/7 cable news and
when there wasn't Twitter could Donald
Trump happen in a world where there's
not 24/7 cable news and Twitter I don't
know the answer to that but he seems to
be sort of the unique man for this
moment and so many different factors are
culminating leading us to him including
look the celebrities ation of politics
you know I'm sure you've seen what's the
Mike judge movie idiocracy oh yeah
were you I feel like we're living in
president Camacho yes I mean that's very
similar to what throughout the Trump
sort of macho thing about like I'm
winning in the polls or exactly we're in
the idiocracy in fact we almost caught
it it wasn't gonna be idiocracy I can't
remember but there was a name where that
was the there was a pun we ended up we
dumped to fail but there was an an early
early idea that was like a play on
idiocracy yeah well not to give the
impression that you think you're smarter
than with the color Shepherd shepherd
college in Shepherdstown West Virginia I
also went to a community college and I
might you know I'm sure Donald Trump
could fever you feverishly be looking
through my SAT scores to show that I'm
that I'm knowing a lot no I am not in
any way advocating like a sort of like
you know world where we are ruled by the
best and brightest to race not at all so
I actually think that you know part of
the reason that I'm so angry and turned
off to the Trump phenomenon is that I
feel like he's exploiting people like me
and like where I came from I come from
Western Maryland and I feel like he is
sort of manipulating some of the good
folks that I and in fact Trump
supporters happen in the best of
families and I even have some of my love
yeah
well you know I've um I've taken some
heat for suggesting that Trump should
have run in a third party even if that
meant Republicans lost the White House
because the damage he is doing to the
party and the brand is it's done it's
already done and it's it's looking a
reparable I mean we made some great
inroads after 2012 in that autopsy with
younger people women minorities and it
feels like he's unraveled a lot of that
well trumpism and the Trump strategy and
the Trump coalition goes completely
against that autopsy like anything that
a smart person would have said like well
if we're gonna win the future we need to
do a B and C he's saying no we're gonna
do you know D well he doesn't care about
the health of the party no cuz that's
the establishment and what I think I am
more optimistic than you though in terms
of I don't think the damage yet is
irreparable okay I think a Donald Trump
nominee would send a horrible message
only to a lot of Americans about what
the Republican Party stands for I still
think that you could end up with a
Republican Party that is a party that
looks like a Marco Rubio Paul Ryan
optimistic solutions oriented
conservative forward-looking 21st
century Regan Kemp conservatism that
would be incredibly appealing and could
go up against Hillary Clinton and her
again
what was it Rubio said in his
announcement yesterday a candidate from
yesterday great ideas from yesterday I
mean the contrasts mean she would become
a bridge to the past and conservatism
could be a bridge to the future so let's
say in your and my ideal world Marco
Rubio wins the nomination and we have
this great standard-bearer who's a lot
more adept at reaching out to these
various groups that we we want included
in our party politics where does Donald
Trump go and more importantly where do
the angry Donald Trump supporters go and
I don't mean who do they vote for I mean
where do they go where does that anger
go and and how do we deal with as a
party the reality
that they're still out there without you
know completely writing them off right
so the one question is where does a ton
of Trump go I have no idea where he goes
and it's interesting to game out like
what kind of damage could he do like
does he come into the fold and you'd be
a good soldier does he go rogue I think
it's practically expected late for a
third party but he could cause a lot of
trouble just talking and undermining
candidates so that's that's a wild card
I don't know the answer to that I do
know that Republicans and conservatives
have to find a way to bring most of his
supporters into the fold and while I
think that a lot of them are misguided I
think that they are by and large
probably good Americans who are
sincerely angry and frustrated and in
many cases have been we have not lived
up to the promise of the American dream
that they were that they were promised
and I see I mean I see it happening and
and where I'm from the old days where
you could graduate from high school and
have a middle-class lifestyle those days
are gone and it's unfortunate it really
it's it's sad for people who I mean I
see my parents generation middle-class
lifestyle owned their own home and some
of their kids are not living that living
that dream so how do we bring how do we
bring them into the fold I think it's
very important that we this sort of this
surgical-strike to take out Trump but
not go after the people right and and
belittle and purge the people who
believe in I hope that some of these
problems fix themselves
I mean if we actually get a president in
there who stops Isis from beheading
Christians who helps turn around the
economy some of this anger and
frustration that's very legitimate would
subside and this could we could look
back at this as being a moment in
history just like the Perot moment or
the you can--and moment where people
wanted to take out their pitchforks and
their torches and now they put them away
and they got a nice job and they're
drinking you know lattes and you know
pretty I'm riding in ubers and and we
can all be happy and coexist is a big
you know conservative movement again but
specifically on this election let's say
let's say it's Marco I mean Ted Cruz got
I think deservingly some
FLAC for bear-hugging Trump as long as
he did and that was to collect his
voters when Donald Trump you know went
away and it looks like he's successfully
collecting some of these voters although
after Iowa we learned that some Trump
voters went to Marco Rubio but if you're
Marco Rubio how do you how do you say
Trump is wrong Trump is not the right
messenger for our party but I'm somehow
the guy for you guys well I think what
Rubio is talking about is how he's the
guy who can unite the party about how I
think he's talking about how he's the
the candidate who's optimistic and about
how he can appeal to a lot of Americans
and actually I think that's not what
Trump supporters want to hear now what
they want to hear but I think Rubio can
make an electability argument to that
he's the best candidate to go up against
Hillary and I mean I just I think it's
very rare for a political party to go
backwards generationally and Democrats
are being asked to do some very
difficult things I mean again as many
problems as I document Republicans have
Democrats have some problems - yeah one
it's hard to win three presidential
elections in a row that's what they have
to do - it's very difficult for a
political party and rare to go backwards
you know backwards and in terms of
generationally and that's what Democrats
are gonna have to do it's a bridge to
the past and Rubio is the candidate who
can run and he won't even have to say it
because just a split screen picture of
Marco Rubio who has that sort of young
kennedy-esque look about him versus
Hillary Clinton or Bernie Sanders or
[Laughter]
yeah a socialist and a sort of a
grandfather of uncle or a kind of guy
yeah Rubio would be a stark contrast to
them okay so well let's let's talk
briefly about the Democrats I I tend to
agree I think Marco Rubio would be the
best contrast against someone like
Hillary Clinton but you know what she's
gonna say about him that he's untested
that he's inexperienced that you know
she's been painting every Republican
candidate with a trump brush right how
does he survive that well I guess first
I would say when is the last time
somebody won by arguing the
they were the more experienced candidate
and the other person's like an
experienced salon or right I mean let's
see if people if voters not I'm not
saying this is a good instinct but if
voters really cared about experience
then George HW Bush would have beaten
Bill Clinton right Al Gore would have
beaten George W I guess he did win the
popular vote so that was enough Bob Dole
would have certainly yeah Wow I mean so
so I think that the the notion that
she's gonna destroy him because she's
got experience and he's just got this
youthful energy I don't buy that notion
I you know so that's part of it I think
that Rubio also it's gonna be really
hard to pin him as a Donald Trump kind
of guy partly because just in terms of
his his the embody embodies
biographically the the immigrant story
the American Dream story it's hard to
pin that on him and then I think he's
just he's a really eloquent communicator
I mean compared to say like a Mitt
Romney who just didn't have it it was
kind of easy to tag you know to unfairly
the world women's stuff attribute that
to him I think it's gonna be much harder
to get Ruby to sort of cast Rubio as
like a you know evil mean old Republican
interestingly I think that Trump and
Rubio could both run good campaigns
against Hillary in very different ways I
think you know Trump would be like the
power pitcher who's like brushing people
back off the plate and throwing hundred
mile per hour per hour fast balls at
Hillary I think Rubio is more like the
finesse pitcher who'd be kind of working
the edges and painting the corners and
finessing it a little bit but I think
they could both be effective against
Hillary so are you then you're sanguine
about Republicans chances for the White
House I am probably more optimistic than
a lot of people are my real concern
about conservatism in the Republican
Party is really more long-term than
short-term and it's especially if Donald
Trump becomes a standard bearer the
long-term damage that I think that could
do it really sets back everything that
you would do to try to build a party or
a movement that could win the future
let's just talk about you know
in Texas in about 20 years
whites are gonna constitute or Anglos
are gonna constitute about something
like 38 percent of the electorate so the
good news is that John Cornyn a Texas
Republican actually won the Hispanic
vote as recently as 2014 proving that it
can be done as long as Republicans don't
continue to go out of their way to
alienate Hispanics but think of it this
way if you ever look at an electoral map
you know the red states in the blue
states right now Republicans have a hard
time winning the electoral college and
that's when you start off with Texas
being a red state what happens if Texas
becomes a purple state it's pretty much
game over right Republicans could still
win House races and state legislatures
but if you know if Texas becomes a swing
state if Republicans can't just pencil
that one ad and if it goes with
California and New York
it's it's game over and we could be
headed that way if we're not careful
yeah well you just brought up a really
interesting point that obviously we've
done very well in midterm elections
passed a couple of them we've done
really well state houses and we've not
done well nationally and lost five out
of the popular vote in five out of the
last six right what what what do you see
as the answer the reason why we are so
good in state and local elections and so
bad at becoming president again yeah
well I think part of it is Republicans
deserve credit for focusing on the power
and the importance of state and local
elections and Attorneys General and
other sort of below the radar positions
that are incredibly powerful I think
some of it is not so positive it's a
fact that Republicans do better when
there's low turnout in midterms than
they do in high turnout and I think
there's a danger that we could have a
paradigm where by the Democratic Party
basically becomes the party that always
wins the presidency and the Republican
Party becomes the party that controls
Congress and I'll tell you the problem
with that as you look at what's happened
in the last eight years you want to talk
about nuclear deals with Iran
you want to talk about executive orders
that I think are unconstitutional the
presidency is incredibly important and
if Republicans keep going down this path
where they essentially concede national
elections and high turnout presidential
elections
it's gonna be like the Obama years well
and speaking of the Obama years they've
been marked by incredible gridlock and
partisanship and divisive Ness I don't
think that's all the fault of
Republicans I think that President Obama
has been incredibly divisive and
intentionally divisive president but who
is who is best to to make that change
and and frankly do conservatives want
that to change
I mean conservatives seem to really
gravitate in some respects to people
like Ted Cruz who were seen as just
being a thorn in the side of Democrats
and many Republicans as well so do we
want do we want to start reaching across
the aisle again and and you know get
stuff done or do we want to really dig
our feet in what's funny you know and to
dump to fail I talked about compromise
and we're sitting here every word it is
but we're sitting here in Washington DC
a swamp that would not be the capital if
it weren't for compromise and it had to
do with you know Thomas Jefferson
basically having a dinner party so the
legend goes and working out a deal where
you know certain states would work it
would pay debts from the Revolutionary
War and return for moving the capital
here to Washington DC and so our you
know our country sort of begins with
compromises yeah and it's not always a
dirty word it's bad when you compromise
your values but if we're gonna like are
we gonna where we're gonna go to dinner
tonight I'm cool with that kind of
comment that kind of compromise I think
that what we're at what happened is that
I think Obama has poisoned the well and
I think that we now have this sort of a
tit-for-tat
situation where like people have
negotiated in bad faith they don't trust
us we don't trust them and it becomes a
vicious cycle and I think we just need
to get out of that vicious cycle
interestingly somebody like Donald Trump
and this is why you see sort of
establishment types like Bob Dole yeah
say that they would prefer Donald Trump
over Ted Cruz because Trump actually
could be somebody who knows how to cut
deals and when works across the other
now if you're a hardcore conservative
maybe you won't like that but that's
sort of an establishment argument for
Trump as he could get things done know
complete and he doesn't come in with
the anti-obama the baggage right that
some of the senators and maybe even some
of the governor's have had over the past
you know eight years nobody cuts a deal
like me many many people have said yeah
I mean he he takes pride in that and I
think he's you know morally and
philosophically flexible and that's for
sure yeah
gridlock could go I mean bad things
might happen but gridlock might be the
least of our problems yeah well in
quickly a last question give me a
prediction who wins the nomination and
who wins the presidency that's a good
question um I'm gonna I'm gonna go with
Rubio okay
and I think vote I'm gonna go with Rubio
for both and and and and I think this is
I'm gonna take some prodding this is a
gutsy call I don't know what yeah I
don't what I don't know what odds Vegas
is giving me right now I don't think
that there are great odds this might be
like picking the Redskins to win the
next year's Superbowl but I'm like I'm
gonna go with Rubio I like it well to
Dover to feel great book thanks so much
for writing in for talking